well fear is keeping many Asian
Americans from reporting crimes across
Southern Nevada 8 news now reporter Mary
Jane beliesza shares how Metro and Asian
leaders are working to overcome the
the Spring Mountain Corridor is full of
businesses and plenty of foot traffic as
the Las Vegas Asian population continues
to grow which is why Captain Michelle
Tavares who oversees the Spring Valley
command says it's important to maintain
the Safety and Security of the area
historically in Asian culture outside of
the U.S they the police can be viewed as
corrupt Clark County aapi Commissioner
Jenny Kim says Asians may not always
report crimes due to fear of
discrimination or a language barrier
Asians in general is very private very
proud and humble and they don't want to
stand out it's ongoing efforts including
meeting with Asian local leaders and
having a language line to help better
understand how they can help Asians feel
safe Alex Kim the president of the
Korean American Association met with
Metro Police we have a really good talk
about a lot of issue especially some
homeless issue and some security issue
things like that yes we have a really
good communication with it at the Spring
Valley division captain says community
policing and engagement has gone a long
way to help Metro Police solve crimes
had it not been for the community we
would not have solved the Shanghai
shooting so we're very grateful that
that happened and I know he's still
recovering despite seeing an increase in
emergency calls from the year before
Captain Tavares says it's actually a
good thing we've gone up about 500 calls
for service which means we're doing
something right people are calling us
and they're reporting Jenny Kim says
this type of progress is key to show
we're United as a community we need to
start standing out and start talking
about our issues because we live here
and we raise our kids education
everything else it is vital that we get
involved
here are some statistics for Metro
regarding Asian hate crimes in the
valley two incidents in 2002 one in 2021
and three in 2022 while those numbers
seem low there is some concern there may
be more that are not reported so Metro
encourages the Asian Community to report
them and they do have a translator to
help with any language barriers and
forgive me that first year was 2020.